go and welcome to this video next powers
the opponent I'd really like to win a
couple of games down keep spoiling
complete wins against reasonably high
rated players and that keeps my rating
so low so yep take that I don't want him
to play deform okay maybe not before as
annoying no just takes them
night before here Rack Attack e5f night
f5 yes certainly i probably didn't play
the opening all that precisely he should
be fine yeah very fine we not like
better but he certainly is equalized
that's not very exciting but yeah it's
it's what it is to try to press water
out of stone maybe I manage yeah maybe
not not sure why you needed to bring the
King to e8 first time
isn't that an annoying move now 92 c 7
maybe I could have done that before but
it's only as effective now it's just a
piece black result yeah sometimes you
need those kind of games that you just
get a gift once in a while yeah it was a
really nothing opening su five is good i
should probably play d4 just for catalan
yeah yeah yes just equalised easily very
easily a queen d 5 and group d 8 it's
actually good for huh okay then tp2 why
is that so great i would think this but
then a queen move now it is not very
nice you know here just nothing who it's
just absolutely nothing you could have
also just played and just take take and
drew create i thought that is so totally
equal okay Megan OTA is totally choirs
is just a gift gives me the game
basically okay thanks for watching